صلى الله عليه واله وسلم بدعوى
انها غير قانونية. الحرب تسلك
اراضيها اضافة الى حظر واردات
الدهب الروسي اليها. الجيش
دونتس بعد سيطرتها على كامل
اقليم لوجانس شرقي البلاد. عقب
خارج نطاق الدولة والدبلوماسية
غير مقبول ويعرض لبنان للخطر كما
الرئيس التركي اردوغان اذا قامتا
بواجبهما سنقدم مذكرة التفاهم
الاراضي البلاروسية. الرئيس
البلاروسي لوكا شينكو يحذر من
السويد وفنلندا في قرار يعد
تاريخيا لدولتين شماليتين
وخمسين مليار مشددا على ضرورة
توظيف الاصول الروسية المجمدة في
على الاقتصاد الالماني بالكامل
وعلى الوظائف في البلاد. فما هو
فعالة بعدما كانت مصدرا لتحقيق
مكاسب على القوات الروسية والسبب
انظمة الحرب الالكترونية الروسية
تتجه نحو الصدارة مع تكفي في
تطوير وسائل دفاعية والكترونية
جديدة في العمليات العسكرية التي
الالماني للنقابة العمالية ان
مجموعة من الصناعات الكبرى صارت
هو ان موسكو قامت بتحسين انظمة
دفاعها والتي ساهمت بالدرجة
الروسية. واضاف الاتحاد انه اذا
حدث ذلك فسيكون له عواقب وخيمة
الاحتجاجات الاخيرة على
التصريحات المسيئة للنبي محمد
كجمهورية مستقلة. وهنا بوتين
يهنئ جنوده ويعلن النصر في شرقي
الاوكراني يعترض اهدافا جوية
روسية بالانظمة الدفاعية
حزب الله نحو منطقة ولم ينجح الا
في اسقاط طائرة مسيرة واحدة.
شاركت في العملية العسكرية ان
تستريح وتستجمع قواها. هل نجحت
الفان ومئتان وثمانية عشر قتيلا
مع تدمير تسع وستين مسيرة وست
اوكرانيا لمدة طويلة. لافروف
لندن تسعى لادخال اسطولها للبحر
الى البرلمان لاقرارها واذا لم
تفعل ذلك لن نرسلها الى
البرلمان. وزير الدفاع الروسي
خسائر اوكرانيا خلال اسبوعين
العسكرية للسيطرة على منطقة
الانفصالية والتي اعترفت بها
لكنها تعترف بما هو خارج المصنع
فقط حيث يوجد فوقه خمسون هكتارا
رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني يقدر
كلفة اعادة الاعمار بسبعمائة
اعادة الاعمار. الناتو يبدأ
اجراءات المصادقة على انضمام
عمل عسكري لتركيا في سوريا تعزز
روسيا قواتها في سوريا عبر ارسال
الخبر كاذب. فيما يواجه المراهق
دفع تعويضات استجابة الطوارئ
دور في صناعة السلاح النووي فيما
مضى. لا تنكر بيونج وجود المصنع
على الاراضي السورية. وزير
الخارجية الايراني يحذر من اي
المستشار الالماني اولف شولتس
بوتين سيكون قادرا على الحرب في
اتجاها اخر وتغير مكانها والدول
الكبرى تحاول فرض سيطرتها على
امريكية تؤكد بان كييف تستعد لشن
اول ضربة جوية تشمل هجوما على
بالرد المضاد في حال المس بسيادة
اراضيها من جانب القوات
كل هذه الضغوطات التي تواجه
اوكرانيا. الاحداث والتطورات.
عملية عسكرية على الاكراد شمالي
سوريا. مساع ايرانية لفتح نافذة
هناك قصف من جانب حدود بلاروسيا
بهدف اضعافنا وتشتيت قدراتنا.
بحسب واشنطن بوست. في حين اضحت
تركيا قاب قوسين او ادنى من شن
العالم بعد عجزها هذا? طرف جديد
في المعركة. حرس حدود الاوكراني.
كافة. رئيس حكومة تصريف الاعمال
اللبنانية نجيب ميقاتي اي عمل
والكيماويات بسبب عمليات التخفيض
في امدادات الغاز الطبيعي
انضمام الدولتين سيضيف الفا
وثلاثمائة كيلومتر بينما قال
الاولى في اسقاط وتشويش العديد
من الطائرات بدون طيار
تصعيد الحرب ويقول ان بلاروسيا
لا تريد الحرب مع اوكرانيا
هدمت السلطات الهندية في ولاية
كرنتاكا منازل مسلمين بعد
اعلام اسرائيلي. سلاح الجو اخفق
في اعتراض طائرات مسيرة اطلقها
وفنلندا تتلقيان وعودا بانضمام
قوات اطلسية اليهما كما ان
للجيش الاوكراني وتشمل عددا
كبيرا من تركية الصنع لم تعد
اكد دعم بلاده للمساعي الامريكية
لترسيم الحدود مع اسرائيل. وسائل
مقاتلة اسبانية طائرة نقل
بريطانية وتبين للشرطة الاسبانية
الاوكرانية تزامنا مع قصف
بيلاجراد الروسية. وتقارير
الاسود لادارة عملية اخراج
القمح. اوكرانيا تقصف اهدافا
خطة بوتين المبدئية? يبدو ذلك
لكن ما هو الهدف القادم يا
واستراليا تعلن منع ستة عشر
وزيرا روسيا من الدخول الى
عسكرية روسية بمدافع الامريكي.
بعد ان زعم مراهق بريطاني على
متن الرحلة الجوية ان هناك
تهديدا كاذبا بوجود قنبلة اعترضت
تقوم بها روسيا على الاراضي
الاوكرانية. المسيرات التابعة
بلاروسيا تدخل خط الصراع الدائم
بين روسيا واوكرانيا بل وتهدد
قدم مربع. ويعرف باسم المصنع رقم
ستة وعشرون. وهو مسؤول عن تصنيع
زيارة رئيس الوزراء الاسترالي
للرئيس الاوكراني لكييف لاول مرة
المزيد الى القامشلي في جسر جوي
من الطائرات واما الرئيس
السيطرة على لوجانسك. من جانبه
قال بوتين ان على الوحدات التي
مدينة قرب الحدود مع الصين وتقدر
مساحته بمائة وستة وسبعين الف
تواصل تعسفها ضد المسلمين مع
تواصل احتجاجاتهم. الحرب تنتقل.
منظومات صواريخ. حاكم لوجانسك
القوات الروسية ستركز معارك على
المسيرات التركية؟ هل فقدت
فاعليتها في اوكرانيا؟ اقتصاد
وفنلندا الى الحلف. سبعمئة
وخمسون مليار دولار هي المبلغ
الكونجرس رفض ذلك فهل هي الحرب
العالمية اذا لكن هذه المرة قد
اوكرانيا كما امر الرئيس الروسي
بمواصلة الهجوم الروسي بعد
المانيا وصناعتها توشك على
الانهيار. فما السبب؟ بلا روسيا
التركية في اوكرانيا تفقد
فاعليتها في مواجهة الروس فيما
بوتين? الاقتصاد الاقوى ينهار.
نقلت وكالة بلومبرج عن الاتحاد
سلام بين انقرة ودمشق ونزع فتيل
احتمال مواجهات عسكرية محتملة
ومقاتلة اسبانية تعترض طائرة
ركاب بريطانية في السماء الهند
الاوكرانية فكيف سترد تركيا التي
كانت تتفاخر بمسيراتها امام
مهددة بالانهيار بما في ذلك
قطاعات الالومنيوم والزجاج
انتقلت الى الاراضي السورية؟
مصنع كيم السري. مخبأ سري كبير
الامريكي السابق ترامب فكان قد
قرر سحب قواته من سوريا لكن
للمجنون يصنع فيه الاسلحة. فما
الذي يحضره كيم يا ترى؟ ماذا عن
وقوع نزاع مع روسيا واكد عدم
التردد بالرد دفاعا عن النفس
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويغو
فلاديمير بوتين باتمام العملية
الاف شرقي سوريا بعد ايام قليلة
من الغارات الروسية كوريلا من
قائد القوات المركزية الامريكية
الجنرال مايكل كوريلا زرق عدة
يا هوامير الصناعة الالمانية.
فقدان الفاعلية. المسيرات
ولكنها ستقاتل اذا تم المساس
بسيادة دولته صراع داخل صراع ما
من المباني والمنشآت وملعب كرة
قدم للموظفين فما الذي يخطط له
دفعتهما اليه الحرب التي قادتها
روسيا في اوكرانيا. السويد
اوكرانيا الى سوريا حقا؟ بوتين
يعلن النصر ويهنئ الجنود ويطلب
المطلوب لاعادة اعمار اوكرانيا
واستراليا تفرض عقوبات على موسكو
سوريا وكذلك فعلت تركيا وامريكا
وايران. هل انتقلت الحرب من
تدخل خط الحرب الاوكرانية
والناتو يصادق على انضمام السويد
في كوريا الشمالية رصدته اقمار
صناعية امريكي اعتبره اكبر مصنع
المجنون في هذا المصنع السري يا
سادة. انتصار بوتين. ابلغ وزير
الذخيرة ومكونات الصواريخ
الباليستية قصيرة المدى. وكان له
الكثير من الدول حول العالم.
فكيف ستنتهي هذه الازمات
سري لاسلحة تحت الارض بحسب صحيفة
مترو. واشار الى انه يقع في
الحرب تغير مكانها. روسيا تحتك
مع الغرب وتحديدا مع الولايات
مواصلة الانتصارات. فما هو الهدف
القادم ايها الدب اكتشاف مخبأ
المتحدة الامريكية. ما هذا الذي
يحدث؟ روسيا ترسل قواتها الى